Es gibt wohl kaum eine kultur die mit so vielen mythen verknüpft ist wie die mesopotamische
kultur die mythenwelt ist geprägt von den vielen verschiedenen
völkern vor allem aber die götter geschichten der sumerer sind von besonderer bedeutung und sei für die ganze menschheit
sind sie doch quasi die wiege der menschheit und haben unser wissen über das zweistromland
geprägt denn schon diese frühe hochkultur hatte eine schrift wie stellten sich die
mesopotamien die erde vor wie wurden die menschen ihrer vorstellung nach erschaffen um was ist heute von diesen geschichten
übriggeblieben klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ein sehr sehr cooler themenvorschlag von euch aus der web community vielen dank die sumerer wohnten zwischen den flüssen tigris und euphrat
im heutigen irak das zweistromland und sie haben schon damals echt großes geleistet
sie bewässerten ihre felder und betrieben viehzucht was die grundlage dafür bildete die ersten städte zu gründen heute
die grundlage unserer zivilisation ungefähr 3200 jahre vor christi geburt
entwickelten sie die älteste schrift der menschheit und außerdem
beschäftigten sie sich mit mathematik literatur und astronomie ihre schrift diente ihnen
dazu umschulden aufzuzählen land zu vermessen oder wassergräben zu berechnen aber
sie wussten doch noch wenig und füllten diese lücken mit göttern die sumerer hatten götter für quasi jede gelegenheit
unterteilt in out und uhr götter sowie stadt götter die autoren der mythen spiegelten ihre eigenen lebensverhältnisse
auf die götter und ließen sie beispielsweise zusammen mit frau dienern und kindern im jeweiligen tempelbezirk
leben mit den mythen versuchten die sumerer wohl ihre rituale
institutionen und lebensgewohnheiten zu erklären und zu legitimieren und sehr wahrscheinlich ist es auch dass die sumerer ihre götter
geschichten tatsächlich glaubten ebenso wie ihre jeweiligen erfinder sie brachten ihnen opfergaben und baten sie in
ritualen und was hat doch auch hier war es vor allem die priesterschaft die auch die politische ordnung
maßgeblich bestimmte die an die geschichten glaubten im gegensatz zu manch anderen der eher
weltlich oder geistlich unterwegs war der schöpfungsmythos wie ist alles entstanden
einheitlich sind die sumerische mythen rund um die schöpfung nicht zum einen existiert wohl die vorstellung
dass eine kosmische heilige hochzeit statt gefunden haben sollte zwischen himmel und erde
dadurch wurde die erde fruchtbar
andere quellen nennen die göttin nano
als die schöpferin von himmel und erde sie soll beides geboren haben doch warum wurde der mensch nach den
vorstellungen der sumerer überhaupt geboren die götter hatten demnach zu viel arbeit und hatten den wunsch
dass dies jemand für sie übernimmt und sie zudem auch mit
versorgt und so wurden die menschen aus schlamm erschaffen wir erinnern uns bibel
an anderer stelle wird beschrieben wie die menschen aus einem erdloch herauswachsen
dass der göttervater n will nach der trennung von himmel und erde mit einer hacke
erschaffen hatte das weltbild so stellen sich die
mesopotamien die erde vor erde und kosmos waren nach vorstellungen der messe porta eine geteilte hohlkugeln
also eine kugel die in zwei gleiche hälften geteilt ist oben noch klarer himmel mit sternen
unten die unterwelt zwischen den beiden halbkugeln ein gebirge mit dem salzwasser ozean namens tiamat
und in diesem monat insel die erde und unter ihr ein weiterer ozean allerdings aus süßwasser
ja und im zentrum der erdstöße
podien und alle anderen länder drumherum bezeichnet wird das als alt orientalisches weltbild das später dann durch
geografische entdeckung überholt wurde bis heute erhalten geblieben
einige mythen gingen in spätere religionen ein ihr kennt sich ja alle die sünden im paradies stichwort adam und eva
nachzulesen auch in der bibel eine vorlage dafür war ein mythos der sumerer der von einem glücklichen land berichtet in ihm gab es keine
krankheiten oder raubtiere
der weisheits genki verlangte nach wasser das cover und der sonnengott otto ließ das wasser aus der erde
sprudeln das glückliche landwirt noch glücklicher mit vielen pflanzen und sehr fruchtbaren boden acht
besondere pflanzen wachsen hier und jetzt könnt ihr euch schon fast denken was passiert
obwohl die göttin
ninja sack es verboten hatte ist enkel alle auf er wird von ihr
verflucht und wird krank die anderen götter setzen sich für ihn ein und ninja sack erschafft acht heil götter ihr seht also
die mythenwelt der sumerer ist über jahrtausende bestehen geblieben auch einige andere geschichten sind in biblische überlieferung
eingeschossen echt irre wie greifbar die mythen der menschheit sind man kann sie
nachlesen und sie sind am ende
gar nicht so
geheimnisvoll wenn ihr in zukunft kein video verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht ihn die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und ihr
verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sensationsfund riesiger sack oft gibt rätsel auf bis dann
bleibt dran